Hello. I'm every politician in
Washington.
Running the country is hard enough,
but explaining myself to voters.
That's impossible.
Most of them went to public schools.
That's why I use Grammarly Government
Edition.
It makes helpful suggestions to all
my messaging.
So you mouth breathing sheeps see
things the way I want you to.
Oh, that's a good idea.
All I have to do is set the party
slider and choose whether I want to
appeal to the country or my base.
Grammarly does the rest, helping me
energize, support, or manufacture
outrage.
Though honestly, what's the
difference?
Grammarly turns typical policy
positions into clear, unassailable
soundbites and changes messy,
unpalatable issues into confusing
but easy to swallow misdirection
like a spoonful of subsidized corn
sirup.
Sugar.
With Grammarly, I can use the exact
same budget numbers to claim a
spending cut or a spending increase.
Oh, that makes things a lot more
clear.
Oh, that makes things a lot less
Oh, my donors will love
this.
Oh.
Oh, yeah.
It can even give complex, morally
dubious legislation a cute title
that no real American could ever
oppose.
You may be thinking "voters aren't
that dumb." Well, we wouldn't do
this if it wasn't working.
Grammarly Government Edition.
Helping Washington shovel all that
bullshit. You people keep eating.
I can't say "Spaz" anymore?